somebody  that  oh  so these are live pictures from brixton  in south london where sarah everard  lived a candle-lit vigil for every woman  killed in the uk  in the last 12 months organizers say the  candles  signal the start of a movement that will  light a  fire for change amongst the candles  lit one in downing street prime minister  boris johnson  saying that he would light a candle for  sarah everard adding that he would be  thinking of the 33 year olds family  and friends i cannot imagine how  unbearable that pain  and grief is the prime minister said we  must work fast  to find all the answers to this  horrifying  crime home secretary pretty patel also  saying that she would be lighting a  candle  adding that almost 20 000 people had  responded in 24 hours  to a consultation on how the government  could tackle violence  against women and girls